we're gonna be doing this week's edition
of analyze this does anyone have any
games that they want to look at that's
the this week or this this lesson that's
the topic is that you have played some
games you can give them to me to look at
okay this was you were and you're who is
your opponent Arthur
okay he's not here no okay okay so
what's your name again
David okay so David was white and he
played efore okay
c5 so this is the Sicilian defense
okay Knight c3 and this is a knight c3
is a little bit less common than Knight
f3 with the aim of playing d4 which is
the this is the the main variation of
the Sicilian is going into the open
Sicilian and then denied Knight of three
followed by d4 but Knight c3 is also a
move and it could become a grand prix or
a closest yeah so he played knight c6
this is a good move this controls a d4
square and now Bishop c4 so if you're
trying to go into the grand prix it's
usually more common to play f4 right
away yeah because this way you get to
see what black's doing Bishop c4 could
have some some problems with this move
where he played it looks like d6 but
maybe Bishop c4 I suppose I suppose
that's east six is a good answer to
Bishop c4 with the idea of blocking out
this bishop and aiming for d5 notice if
you play f4
and then black plays e6 you can play
Knight f3 and then later you play Bishop
b5 instead of Bishop c4 you don't want
the bishop on c4 when he plays e6 like
this so much
86 okay he spends a tempo playing a six
now you could go into an open Sicilian
or you could play yeah you could also
you could also play g3 and develop it
that way you could do that you could
play d4 and then this is a whole
different this is open Sicilian now
you'll probably develop your Bishop to
e2 yeah you could even play a four here
and but it I mean this ship c4 is of
course play a little bit so it gives
black extra options because a lot of
times in the Grand Prix you want to put
the Bishop on b5 but he kind of went
along with you and played d6 and
considering that does bishops out on c4
usually black tries to avoid d6 because
you should you can try to play d5 in one
move so if you're gonna if he doesn't
want to play e6 here you could go g6 and
now the idea is you know if you go into
the Grand Prix this is a normal thing
but you you aim for d5 in one move as
black II 6 let's say for instance
castles 97 now you're trying to go d5
from d7 so general that's why a lot of
times people there are a lot of people
that will here will play different thing
like Knight f3 or even Bishop b5 as a
move here which I played a lot but if d6
they'll go into a Grand Prix once blacks
play d6 anyway this is kind of
complicated stuff I guess but okay
Bishop c4 but anyway d6 kind of falls in
with White's plans but it's not bad okay
so d6 f4 and now e6 there's a little bit
of an inconsistency here because he he
could try to play d5 in one move if he
hadn't played d6 okay so ye 6 it says f3
would be sure to write which piece goes
to the square so Knight of 3 was what
also you don't have to put a dash of
like when you go f4 you just write that
for you don't have to put a dash in
between the F and the 4
yeah so Knight of three now he went
Bishop e7 so black is playing a kind of
a passive set up against the Grand Prix
attack it so it gives white the chance
to expand on the Kings side and doesn't
really head back in the center but it is
playable so Bishop e7 castles Knight f6
d3 okay that's good white doesn't go for
d4 he's trying to keep the center strong
castles and queen e1 is that what it was
Queen e1 like this okay I am not sure
about this movement well it's gonna be
hard to do though yeah but you know if
you could bring your queen up here it's
gonna be opposed to this Bishop over on
e7 you know so there's gonna be bringing
the Queen in this setup with the bishop
on e7 doesn't look really that promising
I would say well first of all I would I
would want to keep my bishop with a nice
retreat maybe like this and then aim at
some point for f5 and the you know it's
a good thing though you don't play you
see who sees what happens after Bishop
e3 this is a very common very common
blunder what could black do here what do
you think
any ideas we'd black huh
d5 yeah defy would attack this bishop
okay and then whatever white takes or
not but he's gonna have to move the
bishop away and then comes d4 forking
the pieces yeah so so it's a good thing
you didn't play Bishop III because a lot
of people might do that but I would
start with probably a three to ensure a
good retreat for the bishop and maybe
then later on some sort of expansion on
the Kings side and f5 is Joe maybe Eve
yeah I mean a4 also but it does it does
kind of give away the square
I mean blocks not gonna go there right
away but there's certain things like at
some point blacks gonna play d5 and then
if you go here it could get hit again if
you go here then there could be this
move and but yeah II for has its points
to it you know it stops black from
playing in general I think like setup is
not too bad I don't know exactly how I
should take it on but I don't think
Queen e1 also it leaves this C to pawn
potentially a little bit problem
well Bishop III we saw what happens
after Bishop e3 yeah I mean that's why I
would start with a three and retreat the
bishop to a to a nice little spot for
the bishop and then maybe Bishop e3 and
yeah you know in the meantime it's a
little hard for black to activate its
position I guess but okay so Queen e1
you played a six so he's he's gonna gain
some space on the Queen side okay a six
now you went a four okay that's that
does give black this Square and now it's
a little bit annoying because c2 is okay
so he um so a for Bishop d7 I'm not so
sure I like this move very much I mean
it's not a little too bad but what's the
bishop gonna do there
you might even kind of get in the way of
supporting this b5 move it's kind of a
routine development I suppose I mean it
doesn't
it doesn't but okay Bishop d7 okay so
now queen of g3 so this is definitely
better than going to age for you see
what would happen if Queen h4 right
what could black do now yeah weird where
- yeah and I take c4 so so yeah that's
so butts Queen to g3 this is you know
okay I think that black should now play
night before at some point so okay
Queen to g3 it's just clean okay Queen
to b6 that moved I don't like that move
at all I think that this puts the Queen
and uh it blocks the b-pawn yeah puts
the Queen kind of out of play and it
also you know White's kind of planning
some sort of attack on the King side you
might actually need your Queen over
there so I think it's one way to because
to try to take advantage of the Queen's
absences maybe to play something like
this first attacking c2 and if White's
defends then black could play b5 to put
some pressure around the Queen side and
with some ideas like C hoops like c4
coming up at some point I don't know
really where whites attack is if white
goes e5 we're not gonna take this pawn
because this will open up this Bishop
may be to come up to h6 but yeah he
shouldn't take the pawn no I mean maybe
even okay Knight d5 is possible maybe
even maybe even something like this is
not is not crazy
how are you gonna break through Knight
can come back to there and meanwhile
blacks gets got some attacking chances
over on the Queen side leaving the pawn
on f4 is you know a good idea here
anything and also some later point okay
there's also this move with c4 coming
really restricting this Bishop and then
later f5 counter-attacking gaining space
I mean White's this attack isn't so
routine
you know this move doesn't seem to
really get anywhere because of that and
then c4 is coming so putting your Queen
over on three three you have to be a
little bit careful about that does it
does sort of sideline it in some cases I
would have this move but no your rook is
tied down there and black and do some of
the same stuff maybe even this because
you're gonna have a pin here on them
let's see if this works out because you
see these rooks Tartars yeah why it
wants to take the people yeah why he
wants to if why he wants to take the
beep on after 20 they have to trade
rooks and then now there's gonna be some
Queen a one yeah so that's I mean
Black's got some considerable
counterplay when you bring your queen
officer but he didn't do any of that he
what did he do its Queen there he went
okay so Queen g3 Queen b6 e five takes
takes yeah I mean here I guess I'll have
to stop but I don't know what black did
because it says pawn takes pawn ever
says Bishop takes yeah I don't know we
could 98 but lots of I mean it looks
terrible for black here this is this is
awful
very very big attack so you won though
yeah oh you lost
yeah yeah no no because it says Bishop
takes pawn here so that's not really
possible maybe he'll let you take the
knight and then took back
seems like white would win then okay I
thought I'd show you the game that some
people showed me outside a little while
ago if I can I hope I can remember
everything least I can remember up to a
point we stopped looking at but white
was winning at that point I guess so
white begin with d4 I don't know what
the level of the players were it seemed
like maybe about twelve thirteen hundred
maybe sixteen hundred I don't know
Knight f6 c4 e6 and then Knight f3 so
the idea is first of all that if Knight
c3 the idea is to play you four right
black can pin the night this is the
nimzo-indian defense so he played Knight
f3 I don't know if he knew it wasn't his
met he's avoiding the nimzo-indian and
black play that's kind of strange but
not bad move Bishop e7 it's very passive
looking move but assuming black follows
up with d5 it's gonna be a Queens gambit
accepted so normal more common move is
d5 and then for instance Knight c3 one
of the moves is Bishop e7 and it's the
normal opening which has been played for
hundreds of years the beginning of the
20th century almost every game began
with something similar to this but so he
played Bishop e7 right away and I don't
see any good way for white to take
advantage of that but other common moves
are b6 with idea to control the long
diagonal and c5 which is the modern burn
onion what ends up happening is it goes
into the same pawn structure as a modern
benoni but with blacks Bishop placed
worse so after c5 usually white gains of
space with d5 and then these pawns are
gonna be traded I like to do this but
it's not a huge difference there's a
little tactical thing we don't need to
go into that
so it takes pawn takes and now black
puts the bishop here g6 and Bishop g7 on
a good long diagonal where it's it's
also protects the King and it creates a
strong play on the long diagonal when it
black ended up doing in this game is
getting the same thing but with the
bishop on e7 where it's much more
passive and he was just left kind of
with a worse position so Bishop e7 and
now I think he should really go d5
because it's I mean otherwise white
takes over the center but he castled so
why use the opportunity to go ye four
and now black played c5 and this ends up
getting into a modern Benoni which is
not a good form of it with the bishop on
e7 we'll be seeing and it also allows
something else but anyway d5 I think is
what black really needs to do now to try
to counter-attack in the center so what
do you think you would do here is white
ie five good yeah gain space but why not
take first and then e5 what's what's the
difference what could go to you for and
it should in fact whether white plays e5
right away or now I mean if a five I'm
gonna go Knight e4 anyway so but what's
the difference between it activates the
bishop so that's why I wouldn't take on
d5 because it activates the Bishop from
c8 it's a huge difference the difference
between having that Bishop shut in for a
long time versus open so ye five was
right away I think better in 94 and now
I wouldn't take this night because after
black to expect this pawn may be weak
but the problem is this Knights under
attack and where does it go if it goes
here black takes the pawn on d4 so the
only answer is back sadly back home and
now I think White's gonna be in trouble
I mean this pawn is too weak on d4
something like maybe c5 would be
undermining the pawn and breaking up the
structure looks looks like trouble for a
white something like that I suppose
maybe d5 I can play I don't know but
it's it doesn't look it doesn't look
like white house so there's checks here
forcing this and maybe maybe immediately
Knight here is probably the best thing
of all attacking this pawn and every way
he goes here then check and White's
gonna lose a pawn or have to step up
with this King proudly proudly and I
mean bravely into the into the attack is
not not what you want to do so
so Bishop d3 it would be a good idea and
then
if black trades okay White's got more
space on the kingside it's a nice
advantage but I think that still blacks
should have done something like that so
he played c5 and white went d5 but I
suppose even better what do you think
white should do no no actually I think
his move was right but it looks tempting
to go if I write but sometimes going
forward is not always the best now this
is under attack and if white goes here
what should block do here what do you
think White's taking over massive
control of the Senate right but King
still in the center and he doesn't have
enough backing up his center so what
should black do d6 yeah don't allow
white to strengthen his hold by playing
d6 instead of plays d6 yourself and now
white centers falling apart and it's a
little too early for I mean he'll
survive he'll get his King out but his
centre is gonna be gone black should be
fine but so instead he white played defy
which I suppose is a good move
if white does want to to try to gain
space maybe take on c5 and I mean first
e5 and then and then take on c5 perhaps
but still blacks gonna get counter play
so I think that his move was good okay
he gains a lot of space black took here
and white took back with this pawn it's
sort of a matter of style because here
White's also stands pretty well but I
think this is better somewhat because
it's much White's to Center pawns in the
center against one really restrict black
here so d6 now you see that this is the
same as the benoni right the same
structure but this Bishop on e7 it's not
where it belongs what do you think
White's to do here though this is an
important moment this is very common
idea in a benoni what white if you play
against it and here it's particularly
important because
if you can restrict all blocks
counterplay its it's gonna be very good
so what do you think white should do
yeah okay that's what we want to do
ultimately and that's what he did he
went Bishop d3 but this allowed black to
make a crucial noe for Yui a for the b5
threatened I guess would control and
control it two different ways so it h3
yh3 right this Bishop isn't very bad
this is it yeah yeah yeah this special
cake could go to d7 but that doesn't do
anything on d7 and it blocks the Knights
both Knights one d7 so there's two
things first of all in the benoni this
Bishop blacks Bishop is pretty bad it
doesn't usually it's usually the best
thing it can do is exchange off for the
night and that helps black to control
the e5 square as well but most
importantly black is really strapped
here and when you're cramped e1 exchange
pieces so black in exchange and it's the
two bishops aren't really that important
here I mean black could black could be
suffering much more than two bishops
that when if he's just hasn't White's
you know if he has no space so a lot of
times in the benoni
mostly in fact it's really something
black wants to do is to trade off the
bishop for the knight on f3 and white
should prevent that with h3 but he
didn't he went Bishop d3 and I suppose
black I think he went a tricky eight
again he should take the opportunity to
go Bishop g4 and white should play h3
here yeah I mean still the most b5
doesn't work like there's a tactical
idea of b5 here I mean the idea is
that's with Bishop on g7 black kid go
Knight takes here and rook would
probably be on f8 so here maybe way I
could take the rook but the idea is that
there's some Chuck here forking the King
and the bishop and then after this the
Bishop from g7 takes the knight and then
black takes the bishop on b5 but Bishop
on e7 can't do that
so that
black loses out again because of that b5
isn't working so h3 is fine but he he
castled oops and now black meant a6
again I think Bishop g4 he should use
that opportunity he went a6 and white
stuff and his plan is to play b5 and
white stopped b5 with a force and now is
the time to play a for noticed of white
play a for it right away which wasn't
necessary
black would not be blocking a6 square so
he could bring the night before night a6
to b4 and the night it's a good spot
where it's kind of out of the way and
also bought it from black and also
bothers white so so but he castled a6 I
personally like if I was I would still
can seriously consider playing h3 here
just and if b5 you could undermine the
pawns and then if white if black plays
before now you regroup the Knight to c4
Square to this this square hope White's
idea is to try to create a blockade of
blocks Queen side and that's that's one
thing but it's ok he decided to play a4
and stop you Phi which is also
reasonable and here finally black took
the opportunity to play Bishop g4 if
white if why God let's say black went b6
or so well okay his plan was probably
Bishop F failure I suppose he did this
notice how cramped black is there's
really nothing he can undertake here
he's his knight can come here but it
can't go anywhere I mean goes here it's
gonna be traded White's probably gonna
bring the bishop to f4 and cover the e5
square so but he went Bishop g4 which
was good and white went h3 and black
should have traded for sure I mean trade
this night off because that Bishop is
gonna be way too cramped and then black
can continue this and plan to go 95 or
maybe even maybe even use this night so
that the bishop could come to its
natural diagonal on f6 and hope to play
Knight e5 and in the other night also
this supports maybe to trade off the
bishops which would help black a lot
because then he would suddenly have all
these dark squares under his control
White's pawns in the center on the light
squares and he'll be left with a light
square bishop
so this Bishop trading off these bishops
is going to really help black a lot in
general but he didn't do that so then
black would get kind of an acceptable
game but he went Bishop h5 what do you
think white should do here what would
you do here
g4 yeah he should play g4 I mean it's
understandable that you know you've got
to be careful when you make this move
that your king is not going to be
exposed first of all you have to watch
out for sacrifices typically in these
type of situations I mean here we can
figure that they definitely just don't
work because black doesn't have enough
pieces around the way King I mean you
can start off by breaking the pin and
then just do that and King each one
bring the bishop over maybe to g3 or you
know pretty soon it's white that's
attacking black on the Kings side
there's nothing really to be afraid of
here so that doesn't work but also you
got to worry about long term weaknesses
but here blacks pieces are so cramped
that there's no way he can take
advantage of the Kings side and less
weights very very careless so what do
you think White's should do now how are
we gonna continue from here
h4 well first of all maybe there's some
tactics like this no there isn't because
this is check on e7 right okay so that
works tactically maybe maybe there's
this one no I'm sorry that doesn't work
either okay
anyway Knight each forecast but what's
your plan to take that bishop yeah okay
but these double pawns are gonna help
like and really the thing is I'm playing
against this bishop this bishop is
really bad on g6 it's gonna be shut in
pro yeah so I don't I don't think and
again remember black wanted to trade
this bishop in tonight I was just saying
you should do that before and hear
White's spending a couple moves to go do
it and I don't think the double pawns
like let's say black goes here and then
you oops let's suppose black goes here
and then you you go and take the bishop
I don't think those double pawns are any
kind of weakness and I think White's
really actually around his King a little
bit we
I mean it's okay it's fine probably
decent position for a white but it's not
I don't think it's really the best that
he could have card I don't think you
should go take that this should own
other thing sorry I'm missing tactics
but maybe there's maybe there's this
move though this is another tactical
idea because the bishop is aimed at the
knight so so so when white takes this
this then suddenly the same opens up
here so you got to watch out when you
put the nights over there on the side
for these kind of tactics I think that
this just works bishop takes e4 I mean I
don't know I mean that good some moves
like this you got to watch out for these
type of things and what this hits this
Knight you know again so blacks still
gonna win upon right or am I just
hallucinating something I don't know but
Bishop takes c4 is looks like it works
so I don't think that each four works
tactically but even if it does it's not
really the best I think I mean but you
should move that night what I think you
should do is night here with idea first
of all this is very important square in
this structure because it blockades this
pawn it aims at d6 and it also aims at
b6 aims generally at the Queen side and
second it's it it's maybe I'll go out
for and try to block in a bishop like
that but I also might just restrict
myself with f3 but I create this huge
wall against the black Bishop and
there's really no way black and come in
on the Kings side so this this followed
by Knight to c4 f3 maybe bring the
bishop to f4 will do some little things
like King to g2 and then we're gonna
start playing on the Queen side some I
don't know I wish I knew how to draw
arrows with this this thing I you guys I
feel like there's probably a way but in
any case nice c4 it's some and you know
f3 King g2 Bishop f4 a5 and after some
preparation rook v1 + b4 to open lines
in the Queen side we're just gonna kill
all of his counter play because he has
no black you know we we avoid any
counter play and there's just cramped
and then he's gonna suffocate you know
just a good way to win a game of chess
but
he Wentz I he didn't go G for at least
not right away he went Bishop f4 I think
which isn't which isn't a bad move but
it gives black another chance to go and
take either lose a tempo but I still
think it's a good idea to get because
you can't deal with this Bishop on g6
blocked in you know you're gonna be down
a piece essentially so Bishop before I
think black went now Knight to d7 and
now white went G for
okay so Bishop g6 and here white I think
when rook e1 and then I'm sorry
he went actually yeah I think he went
rook e1 yeah maybe it was even before g4
I don't remember but you know they
showed me outside but basically he said
his plan was a five what do you think is
that a good plan to play e5 why not yeah
first of all let's this out yeah Eve
yeah e5 is gonna allow black things it's
been a lot of things to get a little
crazy and the white king is it open
actually so it also allows black to
trade this off and then this this point
I think it's gonna be too weak so I
don't think II five is a very good plan
here I mean white could have maybe after
long preparation but the bishop on g3
bring the knight around a c4
maybe then f4 and E five at some later
point but I would say the best thing
here to do is just restrict all blacks
pieces and then play on the Queen side
so instead of rook e1 again I would I
would go with something like this with
idea and now maybe we were to bring the
bishop back we play f3 with my knight c4
will play a5 rook b1 and before and then
start attacking b7 maybe there's some
stuff we can do on the Kings side to I
don't know that but first we're just
gonna restrict all of his play because
here black is cramped so okay so he went
rook e1 I think I was maybe a different
move Ward I know I'm gonna get to the
right position though when Bishop to f8
now okay continuing the plan and now I
went a five
do you think that's good so he wants to
restrict likes Queen site one pawn
holding back to and often this is a
movie as you play in the benoni but here
again I think that this gives black
counter play unnecessarily because I
think black can play this gate White's
gonna take on Poisson right that's the
whole purpose and then Knight takes yeah
this was the position they go and the
idea is now okay first of all black is a
little bit less cramped his Knight can
now come here and he has a chance to
play c4 97-95
he also has maybe some play on the B
file and taking the a pawn of course
will black will be able to take on e4 in
response and even if white could maybe
black would get counter play that way
remember the king is still open over
there on the King said you have to take
some care so I think this get maybe
white still better here but I think it
gives black counter play without Nitin
without needing to so blacks not
threatening any way anything blacks not
gonna be able play e5 and playing b6 is
always been possible but whites it's
going to be very passive setup for black
and white will continue with his plan 92
94 rook B 1 and B for typical way of
attacking and benoni so he played a5 but
black didn't played b5 now i think i
think what black played was 95 at this
moment and what about this move was this
what do you think about that mo what
should i do now
any ideas what would you do here is wait
hmm yeah take on e5 right okay which way
the bishop I guess it's possible take of
the bishop but I don't like the
weekend.a my dark square is pretty
seriously here by giving up that Bishop
black native plate looks later black
will play h5 and try to you know I think
it's better to keep that Bishop it's
very important guard if the dark squares
well this would allow black to really
free his position we don't want to trade
pieces so much here and then for
instance this Knight can come here and
then that Knights coming to you five I
think you should punish them for ninety
five ninety five is a bad move because
this is gonna give black a really bad
structure and black need it to play b5
you know or maybe h5 by the way h5 is
also because because if white goes g5
here black gets some real counter play
now feeling no no bishop was stolen was
on f8 yeah maybe he played some other
move besides Bishop I don't know but but
then black black can black can go Bishop
e7 and attacked the pawn on g5 when
white plays g4 h 4 then f6 and White's
King side is really getting opened up
you know what white does here let's say
Queen to d2 maybe start a start with f6
immediately and it's it's not that easy
for white here there's gonna be a lot of
pressure on g5 next say you have like
this and this comes here and now the
rook comes to f8 and pressure on the F
file and whites whites not keeping
things closed anymore it's not the same
as maybe white still has some some you
know ways to get a good position but
it's it's better to just restrict them
with being able to play f3 which is why
another reason I wanted to move my
knight I mean here you can you can do
this right and then f3 okay this is
guarded this cuts out all that counter
play now Knight c4 is coming maybe black
can go 95 though so yeah each fight was
again something blacks to try to try to
attack White's
white structure and then if the night
like I said if the knight retreats then
maybe can consider playing this way
because now you can recapture the piece
and I think this is going to be too well
this is very I mean okay the bishop is
dead but yeah you know it's a bigot it's
a still this is coming in here even
though we got this stuff coming you know
my blacks got a good game I don't know
what happens if white doesn't play G
that right away maybe because night here
and then g5 I mean this Bishop is dead
basically in blacks threat facing some
real big attack on the Kings side but
the dark squares you know it goes here
and now the Queen's threatening to come
in probably wait should maybe it's too
risky to play that way I don't know in
the first glance it looks a little a
little risky for away but I want that's
why I wanted to play Knight to d2
earlier before this was even possible
from black and we could get the Knight
to c4 and black one has so anyway but he
went he went 95 and this allows white to
change the strut what do i press here
this okay okay so Knight takes e5 now I
can change the structure and this is
what he did which is good here suddenly
he five is blocked so black has no
counter play on the e-file weight has
this real strong past pawn here and most
important this is I artificially
isolated these two are weakened by being
held back and b4 as White's plan coming
up here so this is I think real tough
for black so black played rook to ca
with some aim to play c4 at some point
and I think here white again it sort of
neglected his King side safety he played
Queen a4 and I think this would again
given black some chances I mean blacks
position is bad now but it was never
really that great but in any case it's
real bad I think now but still he needed
to get h5 and now if this and this is
real counter play I mean this is
actually tough for a way to deal with
you can see see that's why you don't
want to push g5 here blacks right I need
to take the pawn if white takes then
suddenly that's falling you know and
then whites it's going to be lost
soon it makes a big difference you're
gonna play g5 vs. f3 but here again
black could still try to get some
counter play like this and trying to
bring the Queen down to h4 and Knight to
g5 maybe Bishop comes in to e 7 to g5
afterwards it's a little tricky you know
it's good black knows what he's doing in
any position you know what you're doing
and you you've come up with a good plan
it's it's causing problems for your
opponent even it's a bad position you
can still fight you know so I think
instead of that it was better to
probably probably better to just play b3
he wants to stop this and Queen over
here really puts a damper on a lot of
blacks play for now and then later on
get f3 in King G to consolidate over
there then maybe can start preparing
before but he played Queen a4 he goes a
little too early now black played h6
which he should have gotten h5 like I
just said 6 now I win rook b1 so his
plan is before although I don't know how
that's going to happen because the
bishop is covering that
I worked to be one and here black made a
fatal mistake
he went b5 so what he didn't he had to
do maybe h5 or something like night h7
planning Queen to h4 and then Knight to
g5 to get powder played on the Kings
side but b5 didn't really hit the mark
so what do you think white should do now
any ideas
take off the song of course I'm Poisson
is very important if there were no I'm
casaba noni would be a great opening I
mean it's already open okay open but it
would be a really good opening because
always there would be b5 in every
position Queen takes is what black did
and now what do you think
chuckle good moves here I suppose but no
really there's there's one that's better
than the others hmm yeah pawn to b4 good
this you see you're in tempted by taking
the a pond maybe maybe you can take the
a pond too because this is this is under
attack
so 94 doesn't because that's hanging
Bishop comes back there but I think
black it's counter play you know here
let's suppose and and there's some
counter play on the B file okay white
should be winning but it's I think his
move was probably even better based on
first glance a pawn is hardly gonna run
away and now White's got big threats B
takes t5 is a huge threat because that
rook on B ones attacking the Queen so
black can't take back and then it's too
connected passed pawn just storming
everything out yeah but I takes of
course that pawn is pinned so what he
did I guess he saw the threat of B takes
e5 he played Queen a a7 but now came b5
another good move so better again I
think then taking the a pawn which would
unpin like if you know I suppose taking
the a pawn is also quite good and Queen
takes but anyway he played B Phi which i
think is
Knight to b5 Bishop we're taking here
taking this one you gotta tell me the
coordinates so you're looking for
something for white yeah why shouldn't
take on c5 because bishop
okay well it doesn't make a difference
yeah I mean I mean White's probably even
here stamp do it this gives a lot more
counter play now suddenly this Knight is
under attack and again King say you got
always watch out once you play G for me
I mean okay White's still even here is
stands very well rook c1 and but there's
no sense in allowing this things to be
opened up so I think his move was good
you could probably take on a six but
even I mean this move is even better I
think because now this pawn is just even
coming to b6 and White's taking a6 and
important thing this is stay that stays
there this pawn stays there and this
Bishop is blocked Lex pieces can't get
into the game
White's Bishop remains they are guarding
the dark squares notice how many pawns
white has on the light squares here here
here here you know so this bishop is
important to guard all the holes in
between you know so this was a good move
I think b5 keeps control the position
yeah I think that's how he won the game
I don't remember the very end of how it
ended but I don't remember where
actually what he did because at this
point it was obvious black was losing so
he kind of stopped looking I don't
remember what something like I forgot
anyway I don't remember what's but
somehow it was it was over fairly soon I
guess after this I mean whites White's
taking the a pawn pushing b6
I I can't remember what's what black did
here
but there's not much obliged so I mean
yeah I mean we didn't really look after
this point that much I think there's a
couple more moves but I forgot what the
what was because I can't see any decent
move for black here either
but okay so what did we learn from this
game what are some of the things we
learned first of all if you have more
space your opponent is cramped
one thing you should try to do avoid
trades right especially the pieces like
that bishop which had no we're good to
go I'm gonna keep that bishop and also
what else maybe try to yeah you need to
keep keep her good Bishop but also also
don't be too afraid of weakening your
King sight in such situation that you
keep control of the position